From a production company that sounds like
they make porn
comes a film with the same production value
as a porn.
In the low budget hit that transformed the
horror genre
into straight up torture porn.
Saw.
See Saw, a great idea for a student short
film that somehow got
stretched into 6 feature length sequels,
two videogames,
and one super fun rollercoaster!
When two strangers wake up in your typical
Taco Bell bathroom
the only way out is to patiently use the various
saws,
slabs,
and guns to weaken their chains until they' re
able to break free.
But instead of the obvious, prepare for 100
minutes of
reminiscing,
"I don't remember how I got here."
playing catch,
and dramatically reaching for stuff.
"My family needs me!"
Almost...have another...idea...
Nope!
Tremble before the Jigsaw killer,
a psychopath who combines the traps
of Wile E. Coyote
with the terrifying puppetry of Jeff Dunham.
"Hello, Amanda. I want to play a game."
Come, saw, and conquer the first in a long
line of cheaply made gornos, featuring
the claustrophobia of being trapped in a room
because there wasn't the budget for more
locations,
the panic of the fast-paced editing
because there wasn't the budget for better
effects,
and the cringe-factor of watching the movie' s
screenwriter try to act
"You could be the one who put me in this room!"
"The same thing happened to me, see!"
"Lawrence, calm down! There must be a way
out of this!"
because there wasn't the budget for professional
actors.
So settle in for the one that started it all,
full of cool, well thought out traps
that the sequels turn into complete parodies
of themselves.
"You must press both buttons at once in the
box before you. However, in doing so, you
will give a sacrifice of your own. Two can
live, four will die --"
Ugh, what the f*** is this guy talking about?
And horrific violence happening off-screen
that the sequels turn into the star of
the franchise.
Who watches this stuff?!
Go to starring, go to starring!
Starring...
Kristen Bell
Robin Hood: Man in Chain
Dental Plan (Lisa Needs Braces)
Awesome Mix, Vol. 1
Rush Hour
This Guy
The Bad Guy From Lost
I Think She's On Parenthood?
Filth
and Cher
Saw 1: You've Saw Them All
Hey, at least it's not a found footage movie!